okay hello everyone once again
i'm smiling studying molecular biology
and genetics at bachelor university in
turkey
i'm working as an undergraduate research
assistant in a cancer biology laboratory
and until now i studied non-small cell
lung carcinoma and pancreatic cancer
in the vat lab focusing on cell cycle
emt mechanism and metastasis
and also chronic neophysic leukemia and
dried up with experience with pine
biotech
actually my knowledge of bioinformatics
and computational biology was very
limited and that's why
i wanted to improve myself in this field
because as you know
as a scientist we need to be able to see
the big picture
as much as the small details so in order
to do this we should have the knowledge
of the big data science and need to
learn
how to process and analyze high
throughput data
so while i was looking for an
opportunity to gain experience and
knowledge
i came across the pine boy tech
fellowship program
and enrolled as an intern for three
months
during this period i took several online
courses about
omix technologies and machine learning
which was a great environment
to learn and practice with hands-on
assignments
moreover there were several quizzes for
each course in order to evaluate
ourselves and repeat the information
so i can say that courses were very
helpful for me
because it was starting with the basic
information and continuing by
increasing the complexity also i had the
opportunity to participate in webinars
like this one
and these were very beneficial because
it was increasing my curiosity for the
upcoming details
so one of the best sides of this program
was to have weekly meetings with our
mentors and other participants
each week we were sharing our progress
asking our questions and discussing them
together
it was a really positive environment to
learn and discuss the topics
additionally when i needed anything
anytime i could be able to contact and
go
and get a guidance from my advisors
immediately without waiting
uh for the weekly meetings furthermore
there were two huge opportunities that i
can benefit from
and the first one is the t by infoserver
which is the platform that we are using
for processing and analyzing the data
and it's very user friendly that even
with a little knowledge you can learn
and practice with it step by step
and the second one is the codonx logic
platform actually
coding was very hard and complex for me
but
this platform explains and shows the
coding with very basic steps so
even though i had some difficulties it
it made coding more enjoyable for me
so my favorite part of this program
was to have an individual project which
was the place to show
our knowledge and the practices so like
the theory needed to become practical
it was a great opportunity to come up
with a hypothesis
and develop the answers over time so
nearly
within two months i completed a project
titled identification of lincrnase as
therapeutic targets in
chronic lymphocytic leukemia so my main
goal was to identify possible
therapeutic targets
in order to be able to trigger the
spontaneous regression mechanisms
which is the disappearance of the tumor
over time
with or without any treatment in
different cancer types
for this i use an rnaseq dataset from a
bioproject
that can be found in cvi basically with
the help of the tibelinf server
i conducted transcriptomics analysis by
comparing spontaneous regression and the
progressive state of chronic lymphocytic
leukemia
i determined differentially expressed
genes among two groups
by differential gene expression analysis
and identified significant genes
through statistical analysis
consequently significant protein coding
genes
were correlated with rna-related
pathways
therefore i investigated the non-coding
genes and found
highly expressed 33 link rnas
with further analysis i identified three
significant increments that can be
important in regression mechanism and
can be used as
therapeutic targets but of course if
these findings are
confirmed by additional studies we can
say that
these found link rnas can be used as
therapeutic targets
so my research revealed new perspectives
regarding spontaneous regression in its
association with link rnas
in final words this research fellowship
program
enabled me to master the field of
bioinformatics
more than i thought and in my new
project i definitely plan to use
high throughput data and perform more
comprehensive studies
and once again thank you to the pine
biotech team
for this wonderful environment thank you